hi there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
we're gonna watch the halo infinite III
2019 trailer called discover discover
Star Trek discovery discover hope is
what it's called if I make a red vs.
blue reference does it date me yes it
does I don't know what you're talking
about
whoa Wow no does that make me get
dislikes where do we stand with this
conundrum oh yeah really quick follow
Paula on YouTube and switch because
she's a gamer obviously if you're on
Twitch you must be doing that
[Music]
33
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Wow he turned into Joel from the last
[Laughter]
it's like the leading game
and the subtlety of his facial animation
I'm gonna talk about it and everything
we watch is just I got cold chills
it has a great Master Chief revealed and
shot that was great you perfectly fit
this one the chief is back
[Music]
looks like the main power cells are
fried I'll shut down triggering survival
mode all right I love it when videogame
characters to talk to themselves out
loud helps me
I hope you're ready
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back and we are active on
needler ahead to your suit looks like
there's a problem the servos in your
hands stay called you get out there life
I'm not this active
oh you see there big guy don't know
status report status before what there's
something we need to see chief No
[Music]
we lost
of service
yes
[Music]
okay so again we need to roll
No hell yeah I'll be back for a minute
and a half and I'm ready to go
wow it's really cool Mother's Day is the
holiday
you're special
I was right
that was great trailer man yeah I know I
love how AI not detected he merely gets
out here at court Anna's voice at the
end yeah oh that was really cool and and
when she was like I chose you I knew
we'd be good together
I know Halo fans in general haven't
exactly been like the gameplay has
always been awesome yeah you know for me
personally I've always loved the
gameplay I don't really play the
storylines like Walter you're not or not
exactly the most invested in this
storyline the department but I know for
fans of the story have been very excited
with what this trailer has has given us
so please that's the word on social
media feel like it was really well put
together from just sight a cinematic
standpoint you know it made me feel
emotions like when he was playing back
the message and hearing like his kid I
assumed it was his kid so that was a bad
joke his kid liked talking to him and I
like kind of teared up like it it
surprised me that I was just feeling
emotional about this situation and then
when it revealed when he wiped across
then I see master chief Lewis out there
I was a cool moment I think like long
from it like a cinematic story visual
storytelling standpoint I thought it was
great because I see this guy who's in
this isolated lost in space a stranded
situation even the reveal after you he
watches the message turns and then to do
that instead of like saying like six
months later somebody know that time has
passed because yeah because he's got the
long hair the beard you know he's got
the the leading action hero did I see it
so many videogames it's not the weed
he's not Master Chief but that is the
the look I usually see and the music in
here was also fantastic music of course
goes without saying that the visuals
look great but I loved how they handled
Master Chief in this story here because
it's just pure Master Chief he gets
brought back to life ten seconds later
he's like status support we need to say
yeah
time to fight you need to kick some ass
like right away peace opens the thing in
the back
yeah there's no time for doom and gloom
just get back into action right away
what do we gotta do to fix this
situation the developer of this game
even said because even though we're not
as well versed in the story time
developer of the game like the reason we
chose to do this I found some random
quote in terms of looking up III
trailers and said that if you're brand
new to halo this would actually be a
good game to start with obviously follow
in linear order from the last game it's
also gonna be sort of a softer reboot
for the franchise which I from
everything I hear from Halo fans I feel
like it was sort of in need of that yeah
I haven't followed the storyline hey
Luth like that that strongly since like
halo 2 so this is me kind of harken back
a little bit more to my childhood when I
used to play Halo a lot more religiously
you know this is great this is great
stuff also it gives you a personal
emotional investment yes yeah it
definitely does cuz like I said you're
watching that thing you're relating to
this guy who's there by yourself and
you're relating to him listening to this
message from his family and struggling
and then the excitement the hope he
feels yes when he sees Master Chief and
gets him in and oh that moment he's like
okay I'm gonna do this please don't die
and he does the thing and everything
goes black and then we're in the obvious
masters yeah and then you see his that
was such a cool moment and his
excitement of that happening like I feel
emotionally invested in I'm gonna bring
this man home to his family right away
to his hot daughter that was on that
hologram alright guys well are you
excited for halo infinite leave a
comment down below you guys can
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell hit the like button
follow Paula on YouTube and twitch links
in the description box
come find me come join me play some
video games together